Oh No
your hard drive is doing something weird
looks like you're going to need a check
here's how you do it
windows Tim and I'll try to over explain
this first of all you need to go where
your drive is located you may count the
ways the many ways of doing this
there are probably a hundred different
ways you click on this folder go to this
PC there they are
you can press your windows hotkey up you
know go here what see in there there
they are
you can go to this little menu over here
right click on it go to file explorer
there they are and there's probably more
ways so get to this Barbara doesn't
matter how just this is you need to see
this drives and what you do is you'll
have remain C Drive which is probably
your operating system Drive and you'll
have if you have any additional drive
you see over here you can right-click on
one of these drives with properties and
then tools and then click check now it
will give you some information based on
what is found
if you click scan drive on your LS Drive
it's gonna be the scan while you're not
booting into your OS because that's
gonna have trouble doing a full scan
layer in your OS so but if you're on a
different Drive if you have like a data
drive we put something else off we
cooked up someone else's driving
customers maybe it's a friend and you're
trying to wrong with it
restore the data or try to save the data
before being this but just in case as if
it's already faulty and some key going
out and you want to get the data eights
after work isn't worse so that's just
something I've learned over the years
same thing right click go to properties
and go to tools and check and I'll let
you do the check right away in the guard
that's not the or restaurant and this
will come back and tell you if it found
it in theirs
so you can check any drive this way if
you have a computer you can just you
have a desktop for example if maybe a
custom built one or something you can
hook it up you can hooked up and drive
someone else's drive with a SATA cable
and whatever and then boot up and then
check it out this way then you need to
have is important here to do that so
that's basically how you how you check
your disk is just just like so there are
other tools to boot you and do this am I
gonna go into those and it's just the
simplest way if you have any Windows 10
computer to to check any dry if you
wonder if it's building or not so I hope
you like this video if you want to see
more please subscribe give me like to
help me out and this channel helped this
video to get seen and I'll see you guys
another time peace out good luck when
you have you have a question boy